deux de vos poupées se sont détachées c'est
le monde réel wow pourquoi ces hommes me
regardent
si on apprend que nos poupées
arrivent à Los Angeles depuis le pays de Barbie
catastrophique
non je ne te laisserai pas faire une seule
appendicectomie mais je'  Je suis un homme mais pas
médecin, puis-je parler à un médecin, tu
parles à un médecin, il est là Docteur,
quelqu'un obtient la sécurité Barbie au cinéma le
21 juillet.
[Musique]
Hé Barbie,
je peux venir chez toi ce soir,
je n'ai rien  grand prévu, juste une
fête géante avec toutes les Barbies
et une chorégraphie planifiée et une
chanson sur mesure à laquelle vous devriez passer, trop cool
[Musique]
Barbie
Cinemas le 21 juillet.
Hé Barbie, je peux venir chez toi
ce soir, sûr que c'est le meilleur jour de ma vie,
c'est tellement  c'est hier et demain aussi est un
quotidien,
certaines choses se sont produites qui
pourraient être liées
Et mes talons sont étrangers au sol
[Applaudissements]
donc vous pouvez retourner à votre vie habituelle
ou vous pouvez connaître la vérité sur l'
univers,
le choix est maintenant  le tien, le premier, non,
nous allons le refaire
[Musique]
tu es censé vouloir savoir, je ne sais pas
tu dois vouloir savoir, ok,
recommence Barbie
au cinéma le 21 juillet. salut Barbie salut Ken salut
Barbie  salut Barbie salut Barbie salut Ken salut Ken
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici Je viens avec
toi
as-tu apporté tes rollers
Je ne vais littéralement nulle part sans ça